ado c'est vraiment vraiment quelle
différence puisqu'on parle plus de
toutes les affaires avec l'éthique et
tout ça on va parler d'un sujet c'est
qu'il ya un an
johnny hallyday y avait hommage national
tout le monde disait à quel point c'est
un chanteur incroyable un homme aimé un
an après c'est assez hallucinant il sert
tellement de choses de lui le fisc
l'alcool les violences la
défiscalisation bref tout le monde se
lâche aujourd'hui aux dires des horreurs
sur lui au point qu'on se demande si on
demande pardon c'est un an après il y
aurait eu un hommage national ou pas on
va essayer de comprendre pourquoi un an
après tout le monde comme ça balance
autant sur johnny c'est notre dossier
regardez on en parle juste après la
semaine dernière la ville airs de johnny
à marnes-la-coquette cambriolé nous
étions tous enquêteurs à l'affût du
moindre détail
le cambriolage s'est produit entre le
départ de la femme de ménage à 18h30 et
l'arrivée du gardien vers 21h
intéressant [ __ ] dérobé des bijoux et
une dizaines de montres
les investigations ne sont pas débutée
mais cette semaine c'est la statue du
commandeur qui vacille
et si le tholy n'était pas ce dieu
vivant qu'on nous a toujours présenté à
johnny c'est mon dieu moi je capote
depuis la mort du chanteur le 5 décembre
dernier les biographies se succèdent et
les langues se délient les journalistes
jolie parfois pouvait être lâche et
quand il ne voulait plus voir un certain
nombre de personnes et bien envoyé
laetitia qui par quelques mots y disait
interlocuteur écouter ou écoute
johnny n'a pas envie de te voir et
certains de ses amis comme son vieux
pote pierre billon qui n'hésite pas à
noircir le tableau
je ne trouvais pas agréable quand il
avait bu ils étaient moins drôle moins
brillants comme dr jekyll et mister hyde
[Musique]
mari volage voire violent artistes
méprisant avec les autres chanteurs dont
jean jacques goldman addictions en tous
genres lâcheté notoire le symbio ni
montrerait aujourd'hui un tout autre
visage
alors face à ce grand déballage vous
êtes choqués ou va choquer je sais pas
comment tu es jetez vous l'aura de
sondage dans un instant ici c'est à peu
près à peu près mitigé voilà choqué pas
choquer ni aux chocs et pourquoi mais je
suis choquée parce que tous ces gens qui
parlent aujourd'hui fermer leur gueule
c'est le mot du vivant de jones
est ce qu'on connaissait bien non mais
bien sûr qu'il ya deux bouquins depuis
mai bien sûr que oui mais bien sûr que
là ils vivent sur la bête tout le monde
le savait monstre sacré dans monstres
sacrés ya monstres tout le monde savait
qu'ils que que johnny avait des excès
avec sa femme nancy on va fouiller si on
va fouiller dans la vie de chacun de
nous ici on trouve à détruire par là
mathieu vous saint-barth en plus vous
saviez qu'il y avait une entreprise de
holding vous saviez mais non mais moi ça
ça mais je pense que c'est un fils qui
était gentil je pense que c'était un
type qui s'est senti qu'ils étaient mal
comptiez qui s'est fait baiser par dont
c'était un pas très beau d'hommes
d'affaires on le découvre pas maintenant
il a toujours été toute sa vie il s'est
fait avoir et aujourd'hui à des tons
vous imaginez ce que pensent les deux
petites les petites de ce qu'ils
entendent sur leur mère sur leur père la
petite fille de johnny les les enfants
de davie l'idée vous imaginez j'entends
dire il déloge mathieu vous pas choqué
qu'on balance sur le sortant et pierre
moi j'ai sorti un livre s'appelle les
larmes de johnny ou j'ai voulu essayer
de montrer qu est ce qui se cachait
derrière
dans ce cas guillon d'argent shoot
humaine et bain rech savez dans notre
milieu
mais les gens le public de johnny
pensait qu est-ce que qu'est ce qu'on
disait sur johnny depuis des années on
disait bon c'est un gentil garçon un peu
peiné un peu naïf et on les aime bien
même quand on n'aime pas ce qu'il fait
est en fait qu'est-ce qu'on découvre
c'est qu'il était beaucoup plus
intelligents qu'on la dit moi j'ai fait
mes enquêtes vous dire qu'il est bon
qu'on l'a toujours su quand rempile il
pas lieu rondot dans le monde c'était
une bête de showbiz c'est quelqu'un qui
a géré sa carrière comme un gladiateur
qui étaient prêts effectivement avec
l'âge quand il fallait et lâche qui
était quelqu'un de très généreux quand
il fallait être très généreux c'était
quelqu'un effectivement qui était pas un
pourri ni un saint est aujourd'hui ben
c'est normal que ça soit pas moi je suis
pour quand les choses sortent quand
elles sont vraies maintenant quand on
sort des choses qui sont diffamatoires
qui sont fausses ça c'est scandaleux
mais il ya un moment le problème de
johnny s'est jamais personne en 55 ans
de carrière lui a posé une question
dérangeante à la regarder les gens
parlent à daniel moi je veux juste dire
pour les gens après voilà moi je mets
aussi du côté je ne savais pas je ne
juge pas je dis que moi en un an si ce
qui est dit dans l'élite c'est vrai j'ai
appris que il avait fait des concerts
parfois avec une mallette de cash dans
la voiture j'ai appris qu'il veut de la
drogue
j'ai appris qu'il buvait beaucoup qu'il
a passé sa pas moins fort j'ai appris
j'ai appris la drogue je ne savais pas
j'ai appris qu'en sortant de boîte de
nuit s'est battu à quelqu'un qui dit il
a donné cinq millions de francs pour
éviter d'aller en prison j'ai appris
qu'il appelait sarkozy la nuit pour
éviter de payer ses impôts
j'ai appris qu'ils avaient des maisons
partout les défiscalisations pardon je
sais pas si c'est vrai ou pas mais ce
que j'apprends depuis un an
c'est horrible mais la d14 il avait
l'horizon à gstaad en effet on le savait
il donnait la parole à à daniel pardon
non mais il est choqué au cfaa les skis
choquant parce que c'est quand même très
très rare qu'on parle comme ça d'une
personne qui est qui et qui est morte
c'est juste un an et demi rapporte
évidemment mais c'est pas ça mais c'est
que c'est le début de toute cette
histoire financière qui a complètement
ouvert les vannes fait tout le monde
s'est permis de dire des choses parce
que déjà les membres de la famille
commençait à se balancer des choses
moi ce qui me choque vraiment par
exemple est ce que les journalistes
aient fait des livres sur johnny
hallyday ils font leur boulot ils font
des enquêtes mais par exemple quelqu'un
comme pierre billon qui était un ami
proche que j'aime beaucoup à pierre
billon mais qui se permet de dire des
petits sur est-ce qu'il en aurait vendu
des livres est-ce qu'il l'aurait écrit
son livre avant la mort de johnny n'ont
cessé au rendez compte
mais juste de citations et pas n'importe
qui et philippe geluck on s'est quand
même quelqu'un de très bien qui dit je
suis heurté leur tête à nos féministes
par ces hommages nationaux rendu à
quelques à des grands fraudeurs fiscaux
comme johnny par exemple voilà je le
disais tout à l'heure dans le livre
histoire de leval et lætitia la vraie
histoire disions plomb alors que johnny
ans qui a signé un cocktail laetitia
vient se planter devant lui laëtitia n'a
pas le temps de fuir à sa phrase que
johnny a déjà soulevé et jeté à l'eau ce
sont deux mousses sur son sur son dos
2-2 petit voilà sur son bateau qui vont
le sortir de l'eau est récupérée
laeticia hallyday y en a comme ça
anémone on connaît la triste et moche
john & ray fait quoi par se déguiser et
mentir voter à droite et furent le fisc
il n'a fait que se marier divorcer se
marier c'est un partenaire silver green
de temps de parole c'est notre ami
sébastien vous vous êtes pas choqué par
le fait qu'un an après tout le monde
balance
non et puis je pense que quelque part il
a peut-être pas fait exprès mais il est
un peu responsable parce que le
déballage part de cette histoire
d'héritage wii plus
le procès va durer plus on va en
apprendre donc je pense que les deux
parties et david hallyday on a parlé
pendant son interview
c'est en train d'affecter l'image de
johnny donc voilà là à chaque fois on va
en apprendre de nouvelles peut-être ça
va après tomber sur laëtitia peut-être
sont ses copains et on va encore ses
ambitions continue de creuser on ne
retrouvera on en trouvera toujours parce
que la carrière a été longue s'est passé
beaucoup de choses
peut-être qu après ça ça ira sur
laëtitia sur david sur l'aura voilà
douze ans avait encore beaucoup parce
que vous êtes paparazzi donc vous savez
forcément beaucoup de choses je lis
s'est passé beaucoup de choses et avoir
la carrière est longue
williams ex est donc automatiquement il
s'est passé des choses des choses ont
été étouffés des choses il ya eu je pose
la question je suis auto magali à
catherine aussi catherine vous n'êtes
pas à vous au choc et non plus qu'on
balance autant messac la question qu'on
peut se poser aussi qu'on se pose avec
mathieu reloge c'est finalement est ce
qu on est choqué que les gens balancent
ou est-ce qu'on ait choqué parce qu'on
découvre au sia sur sur johnny hallyday
sur l'idole c'est ça aussi il ya un
monsieur en public depuis tout à l'heure
qui est un fan de johnny mais mais mais
mais mais de fou et depuis tout à
l'heure il est alors et sarah et mathieu
il est là avec des lunettes voilà juste
derrière la plupart des petits de coucou
de la main voilà
étant guillot frisquette 1,8 à 2 ans et
de 10 pour moi aussi j'aurais fans les
vrais fans visiblement s'en foutent de
tout ce qu'on apprend c'est ce qu'ils
votent voilà c'est quand ils sont en
tout cas très triste mais non c'est
horrible alors juste un mot catherine
moi je ne suis pas choqué parce que ça
ne m'étonne pas d'abord que je pense que
dans ce que j'ai lu depuis quelques
semaines la la moitié la moins c'est ce
qu'on dit est faux c'est la beauté des
choses sont à bout où il ya beaucoup de
choses qui est exagéré
l'histoire de l'évasion fiscale ça s'est
posé en effet de savoir quel hommage il
fallait rendre à johnny qui en effet a
essayé plusieurs fois d'échapper au fisc
en 2009 lorsqu'il a failli mourir à los
angeles
rappelez vous c'est sarkozy qui était
président on s'est posé la question à
l'elysée sous sarkozy de savoir ce
qu'ils allaient faire de jolis mouret et
le débat qui a eu lieu en présence de
nicolas sarkozy avec ses conseillers
c'est de se dire à l'époque est-ce qu'on
vous rappelez vous à l'époque qui
voulait se faire re naturalisé belge
c'est pas moi la claque est sensée
escaut quelle image
or on a quelqu'un qui tente d'échapper
au fisc et il avait acté finalement si
johnny l'époque était mort à cette
époque là qui le rendait quand même un
hommage national que la popularité de
johnny des patients qu'elle met
justement vous parlez comme justement de
d'évasion fiscale et de sarkozy voilà
c'est c'est aux éditions fayard la
ballade de johnny quand sarko a perdu
l'élection de 2012 johnny a été le
premier à retourner sa veste ne plus le
soutenir alors que le président avait
fait tout ce qu'il pouvait pour répondre
à ces demandes les plus incongrus
combien de fois qu'il était réveillé en
pleine nuit par un johnny qui
s'inquiétait de ses impôts et il paraît
qu'aujourd'hui si c'est vrai sarkozy lui
en veux un petit peu pas aujourd'hui
pardon c'était johnny n'est plus là mais
dans les années qui ont suivi
quand il a perdu une élection il y avait
plus un seul coup de fil de johnny qui
maintenant était le meilleur ami de
françois hollande mais comme d'habitude
on n'est pas là pour répondre jeudi
n'est pas là pour répondre aussi à
monsieur est ce que c'est vrai ce que
cette fois encore une fois je ne juge
pas qui s'appelle gérard fauré qui a
sorti un bouquin c'est horrible
oscillant peut en parler a pas de
présomption parce que parce que johnny
n'avait parlé bas qui dit voilà qui dit
johnny bon prenait de la drogue en boîte
de nuit et tout ça et qui dit johnny
c'est celui sur qui je tape le plus
parce qu'un jour je suis tombé j'ai fait
dix-huit mois 18 ans de taule parce que
johnny m'a balancé auprès de la police
pour et c'est pour essayer de s'en
sortir lui johnny est une balance on
apprend des choses horribles et jan
breydel
c'est pas du tout lié pour moi c'est
affaire d'héritage et c'est ça c'est
encore un autre débat aujourd'hui à une
mode c'est de diaboliser les gens qui
décèdent
c'est une mode on a eu la même chose
pour de la rue
et la même chose sur johnny c'est à dire
qu'ils sont pas là ils peuvent pas se
défendre
rien ne peut être prouvée sayan blagues
et des chats c'est une manière assez
sympa sinon évidemment que ça peu de
nouvea bassine tout le problème auquel
ont livré ses traits d'anna temps
comment un photographe comme tony frank
qui est photographe de johnny pendant 40
ans johnny le vire du jour au lendemain
sans aucune raison c'est clairement de
plus leur rivalité la donne ne sont plus
lents que ne te ferait dans la rue non
mais c'est vrai les choses sur des faits
que vous interprétez vous entendez ce
sont des choses que vous écoutez magali
non c'est trop facile aujourd'hui la
vérité fais monter quelqu'un juste avec
des paroles et avec la langue c'est pas
possible d'accepter ça et je peux pas
tout mais david j'entends ce que tu dis
après c'est le principe d'une enquête
aussi une entier pas d inquiéter ses
chats quelqu'un comme dit mon johnny
donc oui à des excès c'est normal tout
ça c'est normal il n'a tué personne
vraiment parce qu'il m'a dit il ya une
mode de la rue denis et tout c'est pas
une mode pour tout le monde dans des
gens c'est parce que des gens peut-être
on a on a en a on a on a caché leur
vraie vie des nomades en est ou encore
des gens qui désirent l'excès quand même
la mouline et puis on va regarder je
vous parlais tout à l'heure de monstres
sacrés c'est ce que delarue était pour
la télé ça a été le premier à ramener
l'infotainment à l'époque en france
des mecs comme comme claude françois
c'est un monstre sacré aussi ça fait ça
fait vingt ans plus de vingt ans qu'il
est mort et on continue en découvrir au
poteau par de nos stars je ne dis pas
qu'il faille tout pardonner mais moi je
suis pas choqué parce que chez que je
veux rien entendre
on a que la partie immergée de l'iceberg
jobros pour johnny on va en entendre
durant des années on va découvrir des
choses qui seront certainement
innommable j'entends on en reparlera en
tout cas est-ce que vous chez vous voilà
choquer ou pas choqué de tout ce
déballage sur la star un an après
[Applaudissements]